now the latest on the food crisis
created in part by the war in Ukraine
Russia's military says it has withdrawn
from an island off Ukraine's Coast as a
good will gesture to allow Ukraine to
export its grain that could be a godsend
for millions of Africans who depend on
food exports from Europe and are now on
the brink of starvation Deborah padda
visited one of the hardest hit regions
in South Sudan
the first waves in 18 months are calls
for celebrations
but don't be fooled by The Greenery this
Village is drought-stricken everything
the chocolate alumuria once lived off
this land it's so dry now nothing grows
in this parched Earth her mother starved
to death last year she's convinced
the food stops coming she says you won't
find me alive next time you visit the
world food program was her only Lifeline
that's now been severed
I'm terrified she says please keep
giving us food we don't acting country
director
says they've had to suspend Aid to
nearly 2 million people because of
rising Fuel and food costs following the
war in Ukraine we're having to take from
the hungry to feed the starving if you
are surviving on one meal a day and even
that one meal is no longer there then
you are facing famine there is a market
but it takes a day for locals to get
there and grow rain is in short supply
Russia's Invasion has vastly reduced
Ukraine's ability to ship vital supplies
to Africa
this marker couldn't be further away
from Ukraine and yet Vladimir Putin's
Black Sea blockade has had a direct
impact on the cost of food here which is
risen by nearly 100 percent High School
teacher Sophie Valentino is feeding the
pinch my main method to the world is to
Disturbed unnecessary was
so that when there is peace
uh will be the U.N will be able to focus
and buy the food to and apply supply to
the needy countries the salary doesn't
go far these days the prices are doubles
wow the Chopra can't even afford to
clothe two of her naked children her
final bag of Aid will last barely two
weeks we just need food she keeps saying
You must help us tell them we are
starving
for CBS morning's Deborah Potter
capoeira South Sudan